today House Bill one called the
protecting children from gender
mutilation act finally passed the
Tennessee House of Representatives it's
a legislation that will ban doctors from
giving puberty blockers and cross-sex
hormones to children or performing
gender quote-unquote gender reassignment
surgeries on children this law which
will soon be signed by the governor and
then officially enacted will actively
save kids from one of the most Sinister
forms of child abuse the world has ever
known laws just like it are being passed
all across the country which means not
only that countless children will be
protected from this evil but also that
the cultural tide is turning in a very
real and measurable way and that's not
something that happens by accident it's
true as the saying goes the culture is
Upstream from politics and so this bill
in Tennessee and others around the
country are in large part of their
response to cultural changes and those
cultural changes are not incidental but
rather the direct result of work that
has been done by many people in many
places including us here of course at
the daily wire